every year millions of people are facing
starvation 45 million of whom are
children while billions of tons of food
is going to
waste globally we produce more than 3
billion tons of food grains every year
more than 30% of it globally is
wasted it's estimated that millions of
people starve to death every year here
at this conference in doart delegates
are discussing how policy makers need to
prioritize people's right to get food
and how to stop many unnecessary deaths
from Hunger National and international
trade policies tend to support large
agricultural Enterprises and
corporations who dominate the global
Food Market it's a highly
problematic um situation when the
corporate sector give the policy
direction to Public decision makers we
have SE seen this in 2021 un Food
Systems Summit where huge corporations
also active in the pesticides of food
sector influencing heavily the um
decisions being made by the UN normally
States should do that fan International
which advocates for the right to
adequate food and nutrition says 60% of
agricultural land in the world is owned
by the richest 10% of all land owners
which along with the corporation's
ability to set prices means it's tough
for small scale Farmers to survive small
scale farmers and small scale um and
local communities they're not able to
actually access the market to sell this
product and so the people are the poor
people that really rely on um you know
the the Food Services goods from these
small scale farmers are not able to
access or even
afford climate change is a cause of food
shortages in countries that are
experiencing severe weather changes and
rely on their own food sources the
country that are most seriously affected
by climate change actually are
subsaharan Africa and this is if you
know it is happening since 1980s when we
have very severe drought Kenya over the
last uh 5 years they have severe drought
because of climate change uh Kenya lost
about 80% of their Livestock in The Last
5 Years but this year Kenya has the
opposite problem
flooding across the rest of East Africa
the story is the same years of drought
then flooding that destroys crops but
the biggest cause of starvation is
conflict something that is also
affecting many countries in the region
like Sudan and Ethiopia alongside
climate change those attending this
conference say it's absolutely critical
that policies are changed to tackle
climate change end conflicts and stop
protecting corporations ahead of
individuals basic rights and needs imin
Kimber Al jazer
doho
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz